for example there's another angel in  Silicon Valley Eli gill who I like to do  deals with and the reason I love working  with a lot is because I know that when  the deal is being done he will bend over  backwards to give me extra he will  always round off in my favor if there's  an extra dollar being delivered here or  there if there's some cost to pay uh  he'll pay it out of his own pocket and  he won't even mention it to me and  because he goes so far out of his way to  treat me so well I send him every deal  that I have I try and include him in  everything and then I go out of my way  to try and pay for  uh so that relationship just ends up so  powerful that the OnePlus One is more  than two as investors here  um so compounding in those relationships  is very valuable  [Applause]  [Music]